hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so in this video I
want to discuss a quick overview of the
regulation of cholesterol synthesis it's
not very complete just a small summary
an overview a kind of a visual more than
anything so we know that we go from
acetyl co a to hmg-coa and take away to
my belonging in the committed step
catalyzed by hmg-coa reductase and
member Lonnie is eventually converted
into cholesterol on that cholesterol
that we're making of course is
specifically in the cells okay
and this cholesterol in the cells can be
converted into cholesterol esters to be
stored in the cell we'll see what kind
of what that looks like in the
lipoproteins videos in fact this video
might be a good video to watch after
watching the lipoproteins videos it's
okay to watch it now before them but
it's also a really good idea to watch it
afterwards
so this cholesterol in the cells can be
converting the cholesterol esters so
they can stay and be stored in the cells
as done by a SoCo a cholesterol acyl
transferase or a cat which basically
just tacks on an acyl group onto the o h
of cholesterol is to make them into
cholesterol esters another thing is that
well actually I'll get to that in just a
second so we mentioned already that
hmg-coa reductase is the main control
site or control point of this process
and it is activated by insulin right
because it's anabolic and it's inhibited
by glucose is catabolic hormones HMG
co-reductase is an anabolic hormone and
that it makes this lipid so insulin
would trigger it goofy long would
inhibit it another thing is that if
cholesterol is around cholesterol in
cells it's going to of course inhibit
hmg-coa reductase from even being
available right we saw in the long-term
video that that
the reductase availability via
transcription of the of the gene to the
translation of the mRNA to cardiologists
if there's cholesterol already around
that's going to inhibit the reductase
from even being available to do its job
so here this is kind of the short-term
control
wellshe's me long term here's the long
term right if I the cholesterol overall
well its availability will inhibit the
available to give the reductase whereas
the short term is the phosphorylation or
dephosphorylation that is basically
controlled by these hormones short term
so this is the short term control here
overview okay now something that's
actually not part of the natural
regulation of it but I think is
important to mention is the fact that
HMG co-reductase because it's an
important control site it's a target for
drugs specific drugs called statins that
that actually inhibit the the reductase
and they're important in treating
individuals with with high cholesterol
levels and so these statins are actually
competitive inhibitors of hmg-coa
reductase so they're important in
treating hypercholesterolemia which will
be mentioned in some other videos now
another thing that I do want to mention
is that cholesterol in cells can come
from cholesterol in the blood or LDL
cholesterol so LDL cholesterol LDL is a
lipoprotein that carries cholesterol in
the blood to tissues and it can be taken
up into cells by receptor mediated
endocytosis and it's important to
recognize that that this arrow here
first of all is pointing upwards whereas
the rest of these are pointing downwards
so the cells can take cholesterol from
the blood and it can take them up into
the cells right and that is an important
idea first and foremost but the other
thing is that if there's already a lot
of cholesterol in the cells that's going
to stop the receptor mediated
endocytosis from occurring which is
important again
I just mentioned hypercholesterolemia is
that this endocytosis will be inhibited
if it's already a lot of cholesterol in
the cells and I would that end up
leading to is that if if it could cause
a lot of LDL cholesterol to stay in the
blood which is also something that's
important in hypercholesterolemia so I
hope this video helps as a sort of
overview kind of looking at like this
thank you for watching thanks for
watching and be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and share the video with
anyone you think might find it helpful
thanks happy studying